we're almost at the nest
[Music]
that sounds like a baby crime for its
mama
[Music]
and
cut now that was a great take
welcome to the start of production of
cliff beast six
thank you for joining us in our bubble
please make sure you're wearing proper
ppe
physical touch is of course off the
table
so i would recommend
making sweet eyes at each other i'll
show you what that looks like
this is so exciting it's like my movie
posters have come to life
you will soon learn to hate these people
we are one of two movies in production
right now if we fail the studio is going
to go down i'm not a magician i know
you're not a [ __ ] magician if you
were [ __ ] magician you could pull a
movie out of your ass oh my god it's
minnie driver oh i love her
this movie's gonna make the world forget
about all their problems
what we're doing is edgy
it's real crystal just did a [ __ ]
tick tock with a dinosaur
hey guys i don't feel so good some of
you tested positive for influenza lauren
i think something's up with lauren which
is the good virus
should we be concerned about you know
this level of vomit
there's some really crazy [ __ ] going on
right now
[Music]
why do you look like benedict
cumberbatch right now hello i'm dr
strange oh i don't like it stop being
benedict cumberbatch
they're keeping us here
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] is getting real on cliff beasts
[Music]
are you nervous to meet the dinosaurs
mom they're not real
i thought there was an elephant wearing
a mask or something
[Music]